so we begin on Russia's border with
Ukraine where the Russian military says
it has repelled an attempted incursion
by pro-ukrainian paramilitary Fighters
the governor of the belgorod region
blamed the attack on what he called
Ukrainian saboteurs the fighters are
believed to be part of the liberty of
Russia Legion and Russian volunteer
Corps earlier on Sunday the groups
announced that they would release two
captured Russian soldiers in exchange
for a meeting with the governor
journalist Julia chapovalova has more
from the Moscow region
these so-called Russian volunteer Corps
it is considered extremist in Russia so
they have turned to the governor of the
Belgrade region with a proposal to
exchange two Russian captured soldiers
for 10 minutes of negotiations with him
in one of the Border churches uh in the
region so Governor gladkov actually
agreed to meet with the representatives
of the Russian volunteer Corps if the
prisoners were alive he said that the
enemy group had entered uh nowhere
Travel zhanka Village and the battle was
going on when he was writing that and he
called the military formations in the
service of the Armed Forces of Ukraine
murderers and fascists and he expressed
the home that all of them would be
destroyed so gladco believes that the
prisoners were most likely dead but
actually he did agree to meet for the
exchange of of those prisoners at the
shebekna checkpoint so early the head of
the formation Denise kapustin he is
included in the list of terrorism
extremits and is considered to be a
Neo-Nazi he in Russia said that today a
great Orthodox holiday the Trinity and
therefore as a gesture of Goodwill he
was ready to hand over the prisoners for
the opportunity to talk with glad Cove
about the war the future of the region
and the future of Russia